So we went from one-half to 0.5,
just by doing normal division.
1 divided by 2.
Well, let's see,
two doesn't go into one at all.
Zero times two is zero.
Two goes into ten five times.
Don’t forget the decimal.
Right.
1 divided by 2 is 0.5.
Now, how do we get from 0.5 to 50%?
Well, let's see.
The reason why 0.5 equals 50% is
because percent means per 100.
In fact, cent is a prefix meaning 100,
centuries, 100 years.
The word cent is one hundred in French.
So percent really means out of 100,
percent.
So what this statement really says,
is that 0.5 equals 50 out of 100.
That's what this symbol means,
out of 100.
So what this means is that if you can
write a number as something over 100,
then that something is your percent,
just like 50 out of 100 is 50%.
Now a trick is that to convert
from decimals to percents,
we just move the decimal point
two places to the right.
So in the case of 0.5, we move this
decimal place one, two, and actually we
have to put a zero there, so now instead
the decimal being here, it's over here.
It's 50%.
And there's a little decimal place
we can think of being there.
Can you practice this by converting
the following numbers from decimals to
percent?
For each of these four numbers, write
the corresponding percentage over here.